how to become a college entrepreneur so
I got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys now home
who wrote in to say hey Evan could you
please do a video on what can I do right
now in college in order to pursue my
dreams to becoming entrepreneurs what
can I do as a college student to get
closer to my dream this is a great
question one I can relate to being a
university entrepreneur myself I turned
down high-paying jobs or paying 80 to
$100,000 starting salary flying me
around the world on these awesome
projects I said no to that so I could
start my own business and I have three
bits of advice that will hopefully help
you launch your company as well number
one passion plus value equals money you
have to start the business around
something you're passionate about if
you've watched any of the videos on my
channel you'll know that this is a
consistent theme and if you look at any
successful entrepreneur any famous
entrepreneur that you look up to look at
how they started they were deeply
passionate about their business you have
to love what your business is all about
the concept there then becomes when
you're providing value that's how you
make money so when you love what you do
and you're providing value to people
that's how you make a lot of money you
could be passionate as much as you want
about something but if it's not giving
value to other people you're not gonna
make a lot of money money comes from
providing god you want to make a lot of
money provide a lot of gal you want to
make quick money provide quick value
that's the equation so you have to find
opportunities that you love doing things
that you can get lost in spent all day
on can't get enough of it and that helps
people in some way that solves the
problem when you can marry those things
then you can make a lot and you have the
idea of a start for a business I have a
Sukkah guide zuga 101 find your passion
that goes through all that in a lot of
detail that you can check out if you're
interested if you're really serious
about it but that's that's the that's
the start something that you love doing
plus something adds a lot of those large
you've merged those two together and you
have the start of a really successful
business
number two is use school resources and
this is something that is unique to you
being a college entrepreneur versus
everybody else who's trying to start up
on their own I started my business at
the University of Toronto and I'm so
grateful that I did
because I was able to use the resources
of the school to help my business grow
where I didn't have resources before so
a couple examples one I would take
courses that apply to my business
somehow and use my business as the case
study right in any course that you take
you you have projects and I would always
take the projects and apply it to my
business somehow so in the small
business course I use my business as an
example where most people say no I'm
gonna set up a coffee shop or I'm gonna
launch a website company I was actually
using my business as the case study and
was able to use school resources to help
me make my business better
I took a marketing course to talked
about pricing and again the products I
used was my own company and I can use
school resources to help me I went so
far as to design my own course with one
of my university professors and this is
something a little trick that you can do
that I found out from one of my
classmates you can completely skip a
course design your own course if the
professor is willing to back you and so
I met with one of the marketing
professors and he agreed and we set up a
course around my company and basically
I'd have to meet with him once a week to
talk about the program and I sold to
universities as part of my market
arsalan scientific software and there's
a lot of scientists at universities and
it not only gave me time to work on my
business and one last course that have
to worry about but I could go in and
start talking to those scientists who
were my potential customers and do
surveys with them and say hey I'm doing
this research project from the
University as part of this course that
I've set up can I please talk to you and
they're way more receptive to want to
help you then after I went in and said
hey I have this startup company that I'm
trying to get off the ground can I sell
you something right so I was able to
leverage the school name and resources
to help me save time in school and also
make my business better so use school
resources whenever possible and number
three is start if you have an idea if
you want to do something just start it's
not perfect don't worry about having the
perfect plan you know the plan that I
came up with from my my software company
change before it became successful and
yours will change as well don't just sit
on
ideas because you're worried that's not
gonna work out because it's not the
perfect idea because you haven't figured
it all out yet you'll never figure it
all out on paper at the start so just
get out there and start see if you love
it see if you get lost in it see if
you're getting feedback and traction and
momentum and people want to buy from you
see if you still want to keep doing this
you know there's some things that you'll
jump in on and you love for a month and
then your interest fades that's not
going to be the business for you jump
into something and just you want to you
want to feel like it makes you come
alive that you can't wait to wake up and
continue to go and do that and when you
find that then you'll figure out your
path so don't worry so much about having
the perfect thing at the start just
start
so in summary advice or how to become a
college entrepreneur number one remember
that passion plus is value equals money
number two use school resources number
three start and believe for those who
are watching you like the video you can
subscribe to the channel see more just
like it if you start at your business in
college university I love for you to
share your story leave a comment below
to help inspire other would-be
entrepreneurs thank you guys so much for
watching I'll see you soon hi every Cal
English here with mermaid junkie TV are
you on evans newsletter subscription if
not you should be I read every single
one and you should too
you